listen Disney we've been watching
IndyMac for about three years now and
we're just not ready to let it go so can
you just give us a break and tell us the
real reason why the series is coming to
an end the show is way too popular to go
down without a fight
we know you've seen the online petition
to bring ANZ back so what are you
waiting for
hello Disney are you even listening to
us and you Mac is wrapping up after
three short seasons and fans are
devastated but hey it's better to have
loved and lost than to never have loved
it alright who's ready to get some
closure and find out the real reason why
auntie Mac got canceled your sister has
a secret baby auntie Mac fans will
always remember April 24th 2019 as one
of the biggest disappointments of their
lives this is when it was officially
announced that Andy Mac was being
cancelled and would not have a fourth
season as anticipated when you think
about it this series is much more than a
show it's a stepping stone for the LGBTQ
community one that's helped kids be more
inclusive and feel more included by
their friends and loved ones since Andy
Mac is Disney's first ever coming-out
story some fans feel very connected to
it and they're not letting the show go
without a fight
avid Watchers have taken to the Internet
to sign the online petition and some
have taken to Twitter to post the
hashtag save Andy Mac according to
Deadline Andy Mac was the Disney
Channel's most watched TV series of all
time and it's best rated too so why on
earth would Disney choose to pull the
plug on it well one of the more obvious
reasons has to do with actor Tony
Westmoreland who played the role of ham
Mac for your information today is my
first day at my new job you got a job
cool Wow a Disney scandal if there's one
thing Disney doesn't like it's a scandal
the Disney Channel prides itself on
hiring kind talented and ambitious
actors who want to make the world a
better place so when they caught wind
that one of their very own cast members
had been arrested by Salt Lake City
police and members of the FBI they knew
that something had to be done
Andy Mac cast members were in total
shock when they found out that stony had
been arrested for some very sensitive
criminal activities Disney immediately
commented on the event saying that given
the nature of the charges and their
responsibility for the welfare of
employed miners they had released Stoney
from his recurring role and he would not
be returning to work on the series
Disney then went on to state that the
series would be wrapping up his
production the following week after just
three short seasons Sony's arrest
happened in December of 2018 but the
show wouldn't receive its official
cancellation until April of the
following year however Disney's comments
made it clear that Stoney's arrest and
the show's cancellation were intertwined
Stoney was let go from his role during
the first half of season three and
Disney went on to conclude the series
without him although it would seem that
Sony's arrest was the only reason Andy
Mac was canceled that just isn't the
case I I saw you just now seen her in
your arms do you mean Andy please what
did you see her made a binding contract
although Stoney Westmoreland's arrests
might have fast-tracked the series
cancellation it would appear that Disney
never intended for Andy max to have more
than three series in the first place the
average Disney Show has a total of four
seasons but some have as little as three
it all depends on the story they're
telling some of the cast members have
made comments that make us believe that
the Disney Channel presidents Gary Marsh
hi plans for the series to end after
three seasons back in December of 2018
Peyton Elizabeth who plays Andy Mack
posted a farewell post to Instagram she
told fans that she could spend the rest
of her life reminiscing about the last
three years so this led news outlets and
fans to believe that Peyton and the rest
of the cast had always known that Andy
Mack was a three season deal despite
being the most watched Disney series of
all time
Andy Mack had an expiration dates from
the get-go but then again it would make
total sense for Disney to form a three
season deal with the show's actors after
all they had no way of knowing how the
show would be received and since actors
need to know when their contracts end
three seasons could have sounded like a
safe bet the Disney Channel is
constantly creating new and
groundbreaking series for their viewers
to watch so while Andy Mack might be
coming to an end on July 26 2019 a brand
new series is bound to pop up within a
year and since Disney has taken the
first steps towards airing a series with
an openly gay lead they're most likely
going to make their future
he's much more inclusive either way
actors have a right to know when their
projects filming schedules are wrapping
up this way they can audition for new
gigs and to get the ball rolling so if
you're totally bummed out that Andy Mack
is coming to an end just know that it's
actors aren't done with you just yet
Joshua rush who plays Cyrus Goodman will
be voicing Waldo in the upcoming TV
series Where's Waldo and Sophia Wylie
who portrays Buffy Driscoll will be
starring as Geena and Disney's High
School Musical the series and in case
you're wondering whether or not Peyton
Elizabeth Lee is done with Disney the
answer is no Peyton is set to star in
the secret society of second-born Royals
an original movie that will be available
on the upcoming Disney Plus streaming
service so how do you feel about Angie
Mack coming to an end let us know in the
comments section and that's a wrap don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up and be sure to subscribe to the
things so you never miss a video thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]